okay so there was a great write-up in
the trends Facebook group by this guy
Morgan or girl Morgan I'm not sure
exactly but Morgan key and it was
talking about hey the founder of Trader
Joe's just died I think Joe I don't know
how you say the last name but Joe from
Trader Joe's passed away and you know so
he dug into the model and said what is
it that makes Trader Joe's work and
there's a bunch of really fascinating
things where they basically broke all of
the rules and I thought it was just like
a great example of of like you know when
you want to do something different or
you want to like make a splash in an
industry like it pays to just change a
bunch of the rules so some of the things
that they do differently so they go
through the rules so they most grocery
stores have a ton of SKUs they're like
oh people want all the options we got to
carry everything that people asked for
Trader Joe's has on average I think
4,000 SKUs an average per store will be
40,000 so 1/10 the number of SKUs the
next thing that I thought was
interesting was they over staff not
under staff so every other grocer was
trying to sort of have minimal labor
costs and they go the exact opposite
direction and try to provide like an
experience for shopping they private
label basically all of their goods so
how do you okay great i over stat
possible i over staff but that's like
expensive so where do they make their
money back they make their money back by
not buying you know not by buying
wholesale and selling retail they
actually just private label their stuff
and have a way bigger margin on their
items so what's an example of that so
like their tomato sauce for example they
will have our salsa it'll be called
Trader Joe's salsa and people will be
like oh I love Trader Joe's salsa and
it's actually the same exact salsa that
somebody else carries they go straight
to that supplier or manufacturer and
they say hey we want our own line of
this and so it's usually a junior Joe's
isn't making it no they they go to
supplier but they private label the that
exact item oh I didn't know they carry
it they can't they get a much bigger
margin because they're cutting out the
sort of retailer and they have all this
pricing power to go to suppliers with
and say hey we have all these locations
so we are already a big customer from
day one we want you to give us our own
brand popcorn our own brand of this or
I'm Brenda that and then on the other
side that makes customers love it
because people will get addicted to this
and they think oh that pret
well that chocolate-covered pretzel I
loved I can only get it at Trader Joe's
because there's no brand on it but they
could actually get that same thing they
just don't know the brand and it's from
some other I felt that exact same way
about a lot of their products and so
there was a there's a few other ones
that I thought were interesting I'm
gonna dig it up but talk for a second
while I just so you guys a quick story
so we're talking about scaling i talked
to max Mullen at house economy listen to
this story he told me that when they
first started who's max small max Mullen
started instacart he goes he goes our
first store was Trader Joe's and they
wouldn't let us go in there and they
wouldn't give us all their inventory he
goes I took it goes it cost 25 grand I
bought everything in the store we
brought it to apartment took a photo
took pictures of every single thing I
loved it it was twenty five thousand
dollars he goes one of everything was
about 25 grand and he did that with
Whole Foods and then five other stores
that's amazing okay a couple other
points that Morgan brought up so no data
collection so they're not collecting
data on their customers they don't do
sales coupons loyalty or or advertising
the biggest expense of their marketing
is samples in the store so they go above
and beyond on samples and don't do a
whole bunch of other promotional stuff
they expand it very slowly
so they've about 500 locations after 50
years and so they really went sort of
slow and steady with their growth sort
of like in and out or whatever and are
they owned by someone at the moment
private company I don't think they got
bought by a parent I think it's
literally like owned by the original
whoever's there's a couple people
involved and so in the end their price
per sorry their earnings per square foot
in their store so they'll earn $2,000
per square foot revenue and like Whole
Foods would do 1.2 K and then you know
Walmart will do 600 K so they're way
more profitable per square foot because
of our sort way more revenue per square
foot because of these these different
changes they made to the standard model
obviously I dig that I we should I don't
know why we didn't that I think it's a
10 billion dollar company overall I
thought they were owned by all these
reason you might be right I don't know
on that but shout out to Morgan I
thought there's a great breakdown love
it do more of that in the groups we love
this stuff and we'll share the
information because yet more people need
to learn from this stuff so that's
actually an interesting
take which is what are the interesting
components that make something special
so we're doing this thing that we're
gonna publish on Tuesday on hotels and I
thought that that was really interesting
and so it's not live yet so I haven't
been able to read all of it but
basically a lot of the largest hotel
chains what they do is they don't
actually own the property I mean sorry
sometimes they own the property but it's
all franchised yeah and so 90% of their
money is made via franchising Hilton's
Marriott's whatever yeah I had no idea
yeah and so that's one of like the
secret sauces which is you have to do
franchising and it's really expensive
like could be ten million dollars to
start a Marriott franchise right very
expensive that's not that expensive ten
thousand that's cheap for sorry I said
ten million oh okay yeah that's a lot
it's crazy and so what we've been doing
on trends and what I always loved doing
which is what's like what's like the the
thing that makes something special what
makes it tick yeah so for example what
software typically it's just what makes
a great software business is like
there's I'm just riffing here but I'd
have to find the exact numbers but it's
like are is the annual revenue per
customer at least $5,000 can you make it
so churn is only 4% a month and then
there's a probably only one or two more
rules but it's usually churn and can it
be at least five grand a year for a SAS
business retirement yeah and so I love
seeing those like yeah you want so what
investors do is they see so many deals
and they talked to so many founders and
they do this for a number of years they
get to see how these play out they start
to do what they call pattern recognition
which has pros and cons the pros is
great you can recognize a good thing
when it's a good thing the con is if
you're trying to make everything fit
your pattern you'll miss the outliers
and that's a that's a big issue but but
it's worth it's still a tool in your
tool belt that you should have so I feel
like it should this should not just be
investors that do this this would be
entrepreneurs as well so you should be
looking at different businesses
industries breaking them down listening
to podcasts like this or others and
trying to identify the patterns of
commonalities and try to characterize
okay what made that business tick what
made this have a different outcome than
that what are the sort of minimum
requirements on let's say churn or
customer you know customer
you for a SAS business to work and start
to get these rules of thumb or like kind
of common patterns in place in your
brain yeah and what what I've been
trying to do is figure it figure out
those on on all types of things yeah
and that's been exciting
[Music]
you